let's talk about the true nature of some
of these organizations we have this
story from timcast.com black lives
matter purchased 5.8 million dollar
mansion from friend who paid 3.1 million
dollars days earlier patrice cullers
described criticism of the purchase as
racist and sexist in an instagram post
according to a new york magazine report
the national black lives matter group
purchased a 6 million mansion in la with
donor funds in october 2020 blm took
measures to keep the purchase a secret
on wednesday cullers responded to
questions over the cash purchase of the
studio city mansion describing them as
racist and sexist she said that the
author had a proven and very public bias
against me and other black leaders the
expansive estate was purchased by diane
pascal the financial manager for the llc
janaya and patrice consulting the new
york post reported the property was
purchased from televangelist sean and
sherry boltz on october 21st 2020 for
3.1 million quote
la county property assessment records
consulted by the post show the value of
the two parcels combined it's one one
house with two buildings at 3.3 million
on july 6 2020 three months before
pascal's purchase
the value nearly doubled after the
purchase of the property on january 24
21 the assessment for the two parcels
shot up to 5.8 pascal told the post he
paid the asking price without
elaborating further within within a week
of the purchase ownership was
transferred to an llc in delaware named
after the property's address public
records show now
i don't know exactly
if this proves anything definitively but
here's what it sounds like at the very
least
there were televangelists who had a 3.3
million dollar property they listed it
for sale this guy buys it for the asking
price which
the the uh bolts is it was what's the
guy's name i want to make sure i get uh
sean boltz said was 3.1 million
about a week later the blm non-profit
bought it for 5.8 where did that 2.7
million dollars go right it seems like
just seems like
it seems like it went to fighting racism
hold a shady deal
to give 2.7 million
to launder it out of a non-profit into
private hands so it is now obfuscated
and used for who knows what i was
waiting for that laundry word because
that's what it seems like it does seem
like it sounds like it's just
a hint of you know
i'm gonna go all the way on this first
of all this blm is a con game all the
way down it is a con game all the way
down they tore this country apart over
the death of a fentanyl addict who
resisted arrest and he the policing was
bad in that story but they tore the
country apart the police don't kill
black people the police are not
prejudiced against black people black
people commit an inordinate amount let
me put it another way an inordinate
amount of the crime violent crime that
is committed is committed by people who
are black
50 of murders i think there's a better
way to put it i think it's uh poor
people
and a lot of a lot of black
neighborhoods tend to be
impoverished maybe maybe but the facts
are the facts is if 50 of the country
this seven percent of the country are
black males
it's not that seven percent of the
country are committing 50 of the murders
because it's a small number the majority
of black people of course are not
murderers at all it's a small number of
bad guys who are black who are
committing 50 of the crime that puts
police in a certain position that means
you are statistically more suspicious
when you go into a neighborhood and
you're black so you get and it's very
insulting and upsetting for a stand-up
guy who's black to get stopped by the
police for nothing right but it's also
upsetting for a stand-up cop who's also
in the majority to be accused of being
racist because there was a bad cop so so
all i'm saying is this is a con game
from the beginning their open plan in
the on their website until they took it
down was a maoist plan to introduce uh
violently introduce socialism and
destroy the american family and destroy
as they call it cisgender sexuality and
they did it through riots it's kind of a
kind and specifically on their website
targeting the family disrupting the
nuclear field yes and but i i i would
love to actually have a deeper like a
moral discussion because i don't i think
we often don't don't go through it um i
mentioned poverty and you mentioned race
but i i don't think you're implying that
um based on race they're committing more
crime just that i don't i don't imply
that i don't think that's true at all i
think the left thinks it's true i think
that's why they want to get rid of uh
bail and they want to get rid of
policing because they don't they
literally the left does not think black
people can rise above and i thoroughly
believe they can so the the issue i see
you know having grown up in chicago
having lived in new york is that uh i
agree i think the stats are the stats
that come from the fbi um i think it's
tied to poverty and then there's the
issue of historical wealth and systemic
racism now often the right says you know
there isn't systemic racism or we
recently saw with jon stewart and andrew
sullivan sullivan said what systems what
systems
john had a terrible argument i think
andrew performed poorly did you see that
segment they did yeah and so so i would
love to get your thoughts on this you
know the way i see it is
crime is tied to poverty and i think
what we end up seeing with like fbi
crime stats it actually generates racist
beliefs that some people believe race is
the component that causes the crime i
think poverty is the component and i
think there are elements of history the
united states going back to say the 80s
see i would i would say culture i
if poverty caused crime uh wall street
would be an honest place
what poverty does what poverty does is
it limits the kind of crime you could
commit the guy who holds you up in an
alley would happily write a check and
and you know steal money from a company
without risking his life well then but
he doesn't have that option is it
violent crime violent crime yeah so but
but people are sinful they're broken
they're criminal and and that is going
to come out everywhere however the
culture black culture has been utterly
destroyed and it was destroyed by great
society programs by the left before the
great society before lyndon johnson's
great society black people were moving
into the middle class
faster than they were afterward they
were warned that the democrats were
warned by a democrat by their own guy
that these programs would foster
single-parent homes and destroy the
black family it used to be that 25
of black children were born out of
wedlock now it's 75
that's more than when democrats were
actually selling their slaves because
all the slave owners were democrats too
they were selling their slaves down the
river to purposely break up the family
it's worse now they finally broke up the
black family when you go into a prison
a democrat will tell you oh look they're
all black and hispanic therefore it must
be black they're all fatherless every
single one you go down that that prison
cell you are looking at one fatherless
child after another it's culture it and
it and you people are poor and honest
most black people who are poor are also
honest you know they're trying to build
uh jobs they're trying to build a life
and all this but when you have no father
when you have broken homes when each guy
has three different baby mamas and all
the stuff you are going to have more
crime and that's what's happened this is
this has only happened since the 60s
since the you know jason reilly the one
of the much better writers about black
problems in america had a book it was
called please stop helping us
and that's what i think the problem is
it makes me wonder about uh the
democrats position before civil rights
and how their position after civil
rights still perpetuates serious
problems in the black community well
right because i mean the the martin
luther king idea that you should be
judged by the content of your character
not the color of your skin has gone out
the window i want to point something you
saw in in california they were trying to
repeal the civil rights provision from
their constitution do you remember this
because of the uh because the fact that
kept them from doing affirmative action
right and so i had a conversation with a
friend who is woke
and i asked you do you know the
demographics of california it's yeah
it's overwhelmingly white i think it's
like 70 white and i said and do you
believe that there are towns in
california that are 90 99 white well yes
of course of course there are do you
think those towns when this law passes
or when you repeal the civil rights
provision do you think they're now all
of a sudden going to have an epiphany
and recognize that uh they should treat
everyone equally or do you think that
those people because by virtue of being
white they're racist will be racist
towards black people with impunity
because you've repealed the protections
a good question right
so
but you know but my point there i'm
sorry just as
stop helping people right that's the
point they they say we're going to help
you with these these things and they
take away
a provision that was fought long and
hard for civil rights well and look at
the way look at the way democrats the
left let's say talk about black people
they say well we want more black people
in school so we in college so we've got
to lower the standards and you think
really how about raising the educational
level of your the crappy schools in
their neighborhoods what would that be
like we're giving them a school choice
okay so they can decide where to send
their kids and obamacare
what is that yes the democrats
continually got that but this is the
problem you know when it comes to
we have we have a lot of problems you
know giving my i'll give you my
perspective from chicago racial
segregation is the norm in chicago
mostly by choice but still the remnants
of blockbusting and redlining so
redlining is when they said you know the
real estate companies or whatever they
draw out areas where they're like will
only move certain people of certain
races you know black people in these
areas near the red line and so you end
up with enclaves
there's actually where i grew up 47th
street 47 south when you cross it to the
north it becomes an entirely black
community to the south it's fairly mixed
a lot of polish immigrants
and what happens is the remnants of
those policies result in
people wanting to move into areas where
there's people of their own community so
it keeps segregation fairly entrenched
but then you also have laws that were
passed that seemingly do the same thing
i've i've talked about how they had a
latino elotes carts the corn with the
mayo and stuff and they wouldn't let
them come to our neighborhood they
passed a law or whatever banning them
from crossing one street just so happens
that one street once you cross it all
the ads are in spanish
so i i think you've got
in chicago a very serious democrat
problem i personally think that they
thrive on racism i absolutely i totally
agree they make it worse because they
can weaponize it to win elections you
end up with chicago being run by
democrats for what now 100 years with
with what how many improvements have
come it's only gotten worse
it's only gotten worse but you know what
if if i may just um
people like to gather with their own
this this country we we forget what a
revolutionary experiment this country is
what andrew sullivan said to jon stewart
was exactly right i lived out of this
country for seven years this is the
least racist country on earth that
doesn't mean it's not racist that
doesn't mean there aren't racists that
doesn't mean there aren't systems in
place that can be uh
reformed but this is the only country in
the world
since rome since the roman empire where
we say if you come over you are an
american you come here you're an
american doesn't matter what you look
like doesn't matter where you come from
if you look at who is
most successful in american i think in
america i think it's indian americans
certainly chinese americans are
successful so it's not color it's not
skin color that's keeping people down
this country is amazing in its ethnic
diversity and when you leave places like
la and chicago that are so largely
segregated like i'm living in a place
now where there are plenty of middle
class black people the couples were all
mixed and all this stuff and you think
like yeah this is what america does it
has always done it there's a special
problem with black people which is that
they everybody else came here to escape
the oppression
they alone were oppressed here and that
is a huge difference it takes a certain
amount of grace to forgive a country for
doing that to you i think they're going
to have to exercise that grace because
it's the only thing that's going to free
them from anger in the past but it's a
tough thing to ask for i think i think
the solution is simple and a lot of
these will people don't want to accept
it if we've already passed laws out
we've outlawed blockbusting and
redlining and other racist overtly
racist policies then the solution at
this point becomes class-based
if
if the left believes that the black
community is disproportionately affected
by historical racism and they're
impoverished because of it lack of
generational wealth then instead of
making race in the law you just say
we're going to provide tax benefits tax
credits to certain families at certain
levels which we do
and then you will disproportionately
benefit black families or
you got to talk about the culture too
this is the thing that gets me about
conservatives here this bothers me about
conservatives because everybody knows in
america and this is still true to this
day if you get married before you have
children if you go to high school if you
graduate high school and then get
married and then have children you
probably won't be poor that's that's
just the stats
however however if you grow up without a
dad if your mom is addicted to drugs you
know it's a little harder to do that you
know it's this is the thing that
conservatives forget about like it may
be a little tougher it's easier to do
that when you grow up in the suburbs and
you've seen it done you know white kids
listen to rap and hip hop which i i'm
sorry i think it's garbage but white
kids listen to it ironically black kids
listen to it and it actually affects the
way they live and their culture if we
don't if kids like rap dude come on no
they like it but they but they listen to
it ironically they don't think oh yes
they do because they they go home and
they see oh my my mom and dad like each
other they're not beating up poses
there's white people in in in these
neighborhoods i grew up from the south
side of chicago everyone listened to
rapunzel i understand what we're talking
about kids listen to masterpiece i
understand that but we're talking about
they weren't coming home to good moms
like my friends mom was a heroin addict
i i understand but again we're talking
about generality and statistics right
we're not talking about the the people
who do that we're saying there is this
problem of crime in black communities
that it's not in white i think you're
talking about class actually because
you're talking about south side chicago
and it's the same as what you're talking
about in the black community so maybe
it's just
it's a community issue i think the skin
color is a false flag that the
consciousness of these people that are
like the great grandchildren of slaves
or gregory grinshaw are still
poor and so they're doing crime and then
because you see their skin color you're
like well it's the black skin color
that's why i agree with that
but at the same time you have these
left-wing activists who make it all
about the skin color and as a result of
that they forward policies that actually
do end up keeping the group down as a
whole i would hang out like i lived in
atlanta it's real multicultural i went
to the normal avenue you know with a
mexican community and i would i would
think words to people instead of speak
because i didn't speak the language and
it was i could integrate really nicely
and i understand what you're saying that
there's a black community i i sometimes
i push back on this because i want to
believe that we're all one community as
a species
but it's a it's a lot of hugging cooking
home home meal made meals a lot of
calling your mom on the phone like
that's not in the white it wasn't really
part of my community growing up i mean
my mom wanted us to have dinner together
but it wasn't that like
hugging love that i sensed in that
community mm-hmm um so maybe i can
concede that they are you know a lot of
a lot of these problems exist for
instance in what they now call hillbilly
communities
and so because it's the same thing it's
the same broken culture and this is the
same poverty except they're white so
it's it's definitely not skin color it's
definitely not about skin color but it
is about cultures that do tend to accrue
in groups of people right so you know if
i put if i put a took 100 people and put
them in a space capsule they would
instantly become a new race right
because they'd sleep with each other and
they would just their children would be
related and whatever happened to them
would have affect them so it is culture
but because people tend to gather
together with their kind and sometimes
as you say are forced together together
with their kind those cultures are going
to look like a surprise let's clarify
that music point you're specifically
you're referring to like the gangsta
culture music not rap as as music
no i i hate it as music but but still
but that's my personal opinion man i
said i don't understand that i think
rap's great yeah
i know i know ben also he said like it's
not music okay folks
that's a huge controversy
all right okay don't even come at me
with that
i feel like i'm home
when i walk down the street when i walk
down the street with my boombox i'm
playing classical music okay
have you heard handlebars by flobots uh
no and i'm not going through that you
are gonna you're gonna love it you're
absolutely gonna
yeah it's it's it's it's basically
telling a story of someone growing up
and then eventually becoming a despot
you know i i was in a an uber uh going
and coming one direction being driven by
a guy one by a girl
both ways they were seeing they were
playing on the radio the same song right
the same uh i don't i don't know if it's
hip-hop or rap whatever it was and the
story was about a a woman being forced
to perform uh fellatio and while they
laughed at her and it was i just wanted
to say like you know this is degrading
it's degrading to listen that's not
indicative of rap that's indicative of a
certain kind of music like a certain a
certain it's indicative of a certain
artist themselves you know what i mean
but if you have a look at
you know i'm on my knees praying or
whatever yeah yeah but if you have a all
i'm saying is if you're listening to
that song and you have a mom and dad who
treat each other nicely that doesn't
mean that much it's ironic it's kind of
it's like watching it's like me watching
a gangster movie i love gangster movies
i'm never going to go out and kneecap
somebody you know but if you are growing
up in a in a dysfunctional house or a
dysfunctional culture a dysfunctional
neighborhood and you're listening to
that it may well become your standard
for how you treat women i think you know
from where i grew up the the
neighborhood i was in was was very like
very multi-racial and that was a lot of
the music everyone listened to
so people weren't going home to uh mom
and dad who were like you know dancing
on date night they were going home to
broken homes so how were the outcomes
in that neighborhood i mean i've had a
couple friends of mine who were white
die of heroin overdoses they almost all
were in gangs and they were white
they're all still very poor and their
lives are
some people have
middle class living yeah oh definitely
cultural issues for sure yeah and that's
that's i think we definitely agree on
that one my whole thing is just like
rap music
is not all
you know just talking about beating
women and doing awful things and
shooting people up like there's rap
music that's very like thoughtful
thought-provoking and matters
this is this is the only subject on
which i'm probably more conservative
than ben so i probably shouldn't get
into this
but i think you made a great point about
the brainwashing power of media it's
like massive it's massive and we're on a
new and a new environment a new
horizon and it interacts with culture
because again you know i can play a
violent video game it's not going to
mean a thing to me but if you're playing
it for 12 hours a day and nobody's
taking care of you it actually doesn't
just just just to clarify when you're
referring to rap are you referring to
about the content of the songs
what they depict well i i would also i
also think the music is is simplistic
but i think rock music is simplistic too
so i'm not the right person to talk to
but i do think the degraded lyrics are
are a problem but so that's just an
issue of particular artists like i mean
there's there's rock music that's also
simplistic trash too you know with bad
lyrics i agree
yes
i haven't liked the song since like
1500's you know what it comes together
i like melody it's melody vocal melody
that's what i'm missing with hip hop i
don't ever get into it really you know i
i have to tell you this is absolutely my
father was a fairly famous new york dj
and he played what was called then
middle of the road music which is now
called the american songbook so as a
little kid i grew up listening to frank
sinatra and cole porter gershwin and all
this stuff one day my father who knew
music really well came home and said
this new thing has come out it's amazing
this band out of britain called the
beatles
and he played it for me and i was like
what eight years old you know wow and i
and i said are you kidding me she loves
you yeah yeah you're gonna trade cole
porter for that and he said no no this
is the new thing i'm talking to like a
50 year old man you know so i i just
stayed where i was i went through the
entire 60s listening to sinatra
i got to tell you i agree
um
i listen to music on the radio sometimes
like well now streaming services
autoplay and i'm just like this song has
no meaning behind it at all right it's
just but you know take a look at um
nirvana smells like team's teen spirit
this song is mostly gibberish
i find a lot of rock i found even a lot
of i mean i actually kind of like the
beatles but i found a lot of their songs
incomprehensible i've got two songs if
you take an lsd that'll help yeah i'm
sure i've got i've got two songs for you
we'll show you um one's wrapped one's
not we'll show you after the show all
all right you know but uh and it is
mandatory
no i'm sorry and you haven't watched
star trek
oh yeah we already did that to michael
malus he is absolutely required
i love star trek michael sometimes in
hip-hop you get like when they're
talking like this you hear like the
melody and the tone you can kind of
derive a melody out of that like the
voice goes up and down when they're
making their sound and you're like do
you like your singing do you like
charlie daniel's band
yeah devil went down to georgia oh
i love that song i saw a funny tweet it
said when i was little i thought that
the devil in his demon band sounded
better than you know johnny and i felt
bad about it and i'm like but anyone who
objectively listens
knows that the demon man section of the
song does sound way better the baseline
the person who started the salvation
army that's what he said why should the
devil get all the best tunes that was
one of the great lines that song's so
good i love that song that went down to
georgia i mean i love the future i'm a
joke where it's like wouldn't a solid
solid gold fiddle way
be heavy and sound crumby
let's let's let's talk about this story
too because we i want to mention one
thing really quickly about this story
because we straight from it but i just
want to make a quick point
i think it is poetically beautiful that
the house was purchased from
televangelists because blm they are the
exact same thing it is a modern
iteration they are the holy people who
everyone knows are grifters and hacks
and every normal person rolls their eyes
out but for some reason have a steam in
legitimacy because they claim to be
fighting for a good cause thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm we'll see
you all there
you